liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
herzlich willkommen den kollegen hier im
saal und denjenigen die uns online
verfolgen
während der korona pandemie haben wir es
auch möglich dass man uns online
verfolgen kann und online fragen stellen
kann weil wir auch hier im saal abstände
einhalten wollen
und für diejenigen die uns vielleicht
über einen nachrichtensender verfolgen
weil sie auch auf dem laufenden bleiben
wollen eine kurze erklärung wir sind
hier bei einer veranstaltung der
bundespressekonferenz wir sind eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation von
journalisten für journalisten wir
veranstalten pressekonferenzen laden
gäste ein die sich unseren fragen
stellen und die tun das
dankenswerterweise auch in diesen tagen
und wegen der sondersituation sind wir
auch dankbar dass wir in kooperation mit
dem fernsehsender phoenix
gebärdendolmetscher dolmetscherin haben
und das sind heute termin riga und
annika rausch auch ihn herzlich
willkommen und wir sind eben dankbar
dass auch in der jetzigen zeit gäste zu
uns kommen und das sind heute der
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
setzt zu einer echten daneben der
präsident des robert koch instituts
professor lothar wieler dann zu meiner
linken begrüße ich professor dr karl
breu spruch richtig bruchweg präsident
des bundesinstituts für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte und ganz zu meiner
linken ist der präsident des paul
ehrlich instituts professor dr klaus
cichutek herzlich willkommen und herr
sparen beginnt er sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe frau busche meine herren
professoren nach gut vier wochen mit dem
märz wo wir in der dynamik entschieden
haben bund und länder auch zu größeren
einschränkenden maßnahmen für das
öffentliche leben zu kommen ist es auch
aus sicht der gesundheitspolitik zeit
eine erste zwischenbilanz zu ziehen
wir ändern uns mit dem märz haben wir
eine sehr starke dynamik bekommen
im ausbruchsgeschehen hier in
deutschland getriggert auch durch die
zahlreichen winter urlaubsrückkehrer wo
sich ja nachhinein herausgestellt hat
dass insbesondere in den bekannten ski
und winter urlaubsregionen
das virus sich sehr stark verbreiten
konnte ohne dass die betroffenen das
wussten und anschließend ja auch in ganz
europa sich dann getragen hat auch durch
volksfeste gab es entsprechendes
ausbruchsgeschehen regional die
verdoppelung zeit hat sich immer weiter
verkürzt für die zahl der infizierten
und deswegen haben wir uns ja bund und
länder gemeinsam zu einer vollbremsung
entschieden auch durch die maßnahmen die
ergriffen wurden die absage von
großveranstaltungen schließung von kitas
und schulen im öffentlichen leben cafés
restaurants viele viele andere maßnahmen
nun können wir sagen dass war
erfolgreich wir haben es geschafft das
dynamische wachstum zurückzubringen zu
einem linearen wachstum die
infektionszahlen sind deutlich gesunken
vor allem auch die relative steigerung
von tag zu tag der ausbruch ist stand
heute wieder beherrschbaren
beherrschbarer geworden
ich finde eine sehr wichtigen der
wichtige ermutigende zahl ist auch die
das seit dem zwölften vierten täglichen
mehr menschen genesen als wie neu
infizierte haben wir haben im moment
über 80.000 genesene von gut 130 tausend
die sich bisher nach den zahlen des
robert-koch-instituts infiziert haben
und das ist aus meiner sicht ganz
besonders wichtig für diese erste
ausbruchs dynamik und dem was sich
daraus ergeben hat war das
gesundheitssystem zu keiner zeit bis
hierhin überfordert bei der bewältigung
der krone epidemie schneidet deutschland
im internationalen vergleich gut ab
das macht uns demütig aber nicht
übermütig das ist ganz ganz wichtig
insofern begrüße ich es dass sich die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundeskanzlerin entschieden haben die
bestehenden auflagen nur vorsichtig und
schrittweise zu lockern
viele meiner internationalen kolleginnen
und kollegen fragen mich derzeit wie
deutschland das macht und bei uns auch
noch so viele intensivbetten zum
beispiel frei sind das hat eine ganze
reihe von gründen aus meiner sicht ich
will 23 nennen
zum einen ist trotz aller kritik und
allen unzulänglichkeiten im alltag das
deutsche gesundheitssystem insgesamt in
einer
guten verfassung gut ausgestattet was
fachkräfte die hohe zahl an fachkräften
angeht ärztinnen und ärzte pflegekräfte
apothekerin und apotheker alle
gesundheitsberufe
wir haben zudem ein sehr engmaschiges
netz auch von niedergelassenen haus- und
fachärzten die auch mithelfen jetzt als
erster schutzwall in dieser chronik dem
i was wichtig ist zu sehen ist dass
sechs von sieben cupid patienten sechs
von sieben ambulant behandelt und
begleitet werden können weil sie vor
allem milde und bilde verläufe haben mit
geringer symptomatik das heißt also die
krankenhäuser können sich konzentrieren
auf die schweren verläufe und dieses
zusammenspiel von ambulant und stationär
ist eben auch einer der großen vorteile
in unserem system und das bringt mich zu
der stationären versorgung wir haben
exzellente kliniken
wir haben kliniken die den aufruf denn
es mitte märz gegeben hat den wir dann
ja auch gesetzlich unterlegt haben
planbare operationen und aufnahmen zu
verschieben
genutzt haben um intensivbetten
tatsächlich auch frei zu machen und
gleichzeitig auch zusätzliche intensiv
kapazitäten aufzubauen so dass es
gelungen ist die zahl der intensivbetten
in deutschland bis hierhin richtung
40.000 bereits zu erhöhen was im
internationalen vergleich für ein land
unserer größe mit unserer
bevölkerungszahl eine sehr sehr gute
zahl ist und wir haben die zeit auch
genutzt und dazu werden den professor
bruch in der professor psycho täglich
was sagen
beim thema medikamentenstudien und
impfstoff die begleitung entsprechende
entwicklungen tatsächlich auch aktiv zu
sein
zu drei bereichen möchte ich kurz was
sagen zum einen werden wir die große
zahl an freien betten 10.000 freie
intensivbetten natürlich nicht auf dauer
so in dem umfang vorhalten können und
müssen dass ich verstehe ich auch die
forderungen die es in den letzten tagen
mehr gegeben hat danach auch die zahl
der operation wieder hochzufahren weil
natürlich für jemanden dem vor vier
wochen gesagt wurde die eigentlich schon
termin hatte einen operationstermin ein
termin für den eingriff für eine
operation eine rückenoperation eine
tumor operation möglicherweise diese
ungewissheit wann findet denn jetzt
diese operation statt
ohne frage eine seelische belastung ist
zusätzlich zu der körperlichen belastung
die da ist und deswegen müssen wir
darüber reden wie wir es schaffen können
so wie wir es auch im alltagsleben ja
schaffen müssen zu einer neuen
normalität zu kommen mit dem virus zu
leben auch dort zu einem neuen einer
neuen normalität im krankenhausbetrieb
zu kommen und wir sollten das genau so
schrittweise mit der nötigen vorsicht
machen wie wir es in anderen bereichen
auch machen mit blick auf die
krankenhäuser das ist eine sehr sehr
schwierige balance
aber natürlich müssen wir beiden gerecht
werden der versorgung der patientinnen
und patienten die sozusagen im
normalbetrieb natürlich ihre versorgung
brauchen und zwar die notfälle
schlaganfälle herzinfarkte wir richtigen
kliniken dass die zahl zum beispiel der
herzinfarkte wie eingeliefert werden
deutlich gesunken ist sie sich fragen wo
die sozusagen sind was da passiert
darüber muss man natürlich reden und
gleichzeitig eben die nötige kapazität
vorzuhalten
aber auch für alle entwicklungen im
rahmen von krone und cupid erkrankung
dabei hilft uns sehr das register dass
wir nach und nach hier aufgebaut haben
zusammen mit der intensivmedizin und den
krankenhäusern seit donnerstag ist
dieses register die zulieferung zum
register auch verpflichtend für die
krankenhäuser und wir wollen dieses
register auch zusammen mit den
krankenhäusern und den intensivmediziner
und dem robert koch institut weiter
ausbauen so dass es besser gelingen kann
noch besser gelingen kann auch auf
klinik gezogen und auch regionen bezogen
daraus vorhersagen abzuleiten so dass
wir dann ab mai denke ich schrittweise
eben auch eine neue normalität im
klinikbetrieb kommen können bei denen
wir eine bestimmte zahl der
intensivbetten und der betten in den
krankenhäusern weiterhin verhalten führt
19 behandlungen denken wir starten mit
einer größenordnung von 25 bis 30
prozent um dann eben schritt für schritt
immer genauer auch in der steuerung zu
werden immer nach dem prinzip der
vorsorge unter vorsicht
zweitens kurz zu den testungen wir haben
über 1,7 millionen corona tests bisher
in deutschland gemacht das sind
inzwischen und 350.000 in der woche wir
haben eine theoretische kapazität in den
laboren von bis zu 700.000 pro woche
wenn die entsprechenden reagenzien auch
da sind aber auch dort hat sich die lage
und wir arbeiten jeden tag daran
schrittweise verbessert ich verstehe
deswegen manche kritik an den tests die
ich in den letzten tagen gelesen habe
auch nur bedingt flächendeckende tests
machen ganz pauschal auch wenig sinn
weil natürlich nach dem test schon
innerhalb nach einer halben stunde
derjenige der gerade getestet wurde
schon wieder infiziert sein kann das ist
ja immer nur eine momentaufnahme
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
zielgerichtet testen auch nach den
empfehlungen des robert-koch-instituts
insbesondere natürlich verdachtsfälle
patienten mit symptomen und deren
kontaktpersonen dass wir aber und das
hat auch schon begonnen in den letzten
ein zwei wochen noch zielgerichteter mit
blick auf pflegeeinrichtungen und das
gesundheitswesen selbst testen etwa bei
der verlegung von patienten und
pflegebedürftigen zwischen krankenhaus
in pflegeeinrichtungen bei der
neuaufnahme von pflegebedürftigen oder
auch medizinisches personal und ein
drittes und letztes thema das ich
ansprechen möchte eingangs ist die frage
der masken und der beschaffung der
schutzausrüstung für die pflegekräfte
und die ärztinnen und ärzte medizinische
schutzmasken sind sehr sehr wichtig für
diejenigen die jeden tag für uns an der
front gegen das corona virus kämpfen
doch dort sind wir nach anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten mittlerweile in einer
besseren lage seit mitte märz haben wir
uns als bundesministerium für gesundheit
direkt eingeschaltet in die beschaffung
allein diese woche sind mittlerweile 80
millionen masken durch die
bundesbeschaffung nach deutschland
gebracht worden davon 20 millionen sp2
masken und diese befinden sich über die
woche und auch in diesen tagen und auch
heute in der verteilung
wir haben zusammen in zusammenarbeit mit
internationalen konzernen deutschen
konzern die asiengeschäft haben dort
auch eben es geschafft bessere
längerlaufende verbindungen aufzubauen
sodass wir auch nicht auf den
zwischenhandel
in dem umfang mehr angewiesen sind wie
vorher und zudem das freut mich
besonders konnten wir in dieser woche
zuschläge geben für produzenten hier in
deutschland zu wissen dass wir eine
erste ausschreibung als
bundesministerium für gesundheit gemacht
haben für den aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten für medizinische
schutzmasken hier in deutschland
sie konnten die zuschläge geben an gut
50 unternehmen die ab mitte august pro
woche zehn millionen ffp zwei masken und
40 millionen op masken herstellen wollen
und werden dafür haben sie den zuschlag
erhalten und auch ich denke auch das ist
wichtig weil mit dieser größenordnung
wird tatsächlich den bedarf für das
gesundheitswesen den wir haben im großen
und ganzen als basis bedarf dann auch
decken könnten und für eine epidemie bei
der wir nicht wissen wie lange sie uns
auch noch beschäftigen wird ist denke
ich diese unabhängigkeit sehr sehr
wichtig abschließend möchte ich danke
sagen
den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
mitgeholfen haben mitgemacht haben mit
einer sehr hohen akzeptanz bis hierhin
und auch darüber hinaus schlicht und
ergreifend indem sie persönliche
kontakte verzichtet haben was sicherlich
auch über die ostertage nicht leicht
gefallen ist ja mitgeholfen dass das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
unsere aktion hashtag wir bleiben zu
hause zum beispiel des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit hat
auch sehr gute unterstützung dabei
bekommen und auch mithelfen können ich
möchte danke sagen allen die nicht von
zu hause aus arbeiten können und jeden
tag mithelfen dass unsere versorgung
gesichert ist ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegekräfte alle die im
gesundheitswesen tätig sind im
einzelhandel verkäuferinnen und
verkäufer für unsere sicherheit viele
viele andere mehr
die unsere wertschätzung verdienen aber
natürlich auch unsere anerkennung
darüber hinaus auch darüber im übrigen
für die pflege sind wir in konkreten
gesprächen
ich möchte auch denen danke sagen die
ungeduldig sind gerade auf dem weg
zurück in eine neue normalität
ich verstehe ist dass diejenigen die
auch vor einer wirtschaftlichen existenz
frage bestehen natürlich fragen danach
haben wie es denn jetzt weiter geht
den nächsten schritten und wann sie auch
wieder sich wirtschaftlich betätigen
können und ich verstehe gut aus dem
eigenen persönlichen umfeld wie auch
etwa eltern mit kleineren kindern die
zum beispiel selbst berufstätig sind bei
der frage wie schaut es mit kita wie
schaut es mit grundschule wie schaut es
mit betreuung für die kinder aus auch
fragen haben weil sie natürlich jeden
tag stress und doppelbelastung erleben
und deswegen ist es wichtig und die
familienministerin hat das ja auch
angekündigt dass wir insbesondere für
berufstätige eltern eine lösung finden
wir wollen schrittweise die richtige
balance finden für den schutz der
gesundheit das öffentliche leben und
unsere wirtschaft wir wollen
schrittweise den weg finden eine neue
normalität wir müssen lernen mit dem
virus zu leben jede einzelne und auch
wir als gesellschaft wir haben stand
heute gute chancen gut durch diese zeit
der epidemie zu kommen als gesellschaft
als nation und auch mit unserem
gesundheitswesen und wir werden jeden
tag weiter daran arbeiten dass das auch
gelingt dafür dann hat jetzt wieder das
wort jeden tag meine damen kann
stand heute mal damen kann auch wenn wir
immer noch am anfang dieser pandemie
sind zeigt sich doch dass die
bekämpfungsstrategie die wir in
deutschland aufgebaut haben erfolge
zeigt die drei säulen noch mal genannt
die eindämmung der infektionskrankheiten
hauptsächlich dadurch dass das lokale
gesundheitswesen gestärkt wird und
seiner infekt ketten brechen kann den
schutz der bullen haben gruppen und
drittens die steigung der versorgung
dann muss man stand heute sagen dass für
eine wirklich gutes zwischenergebnis
erreicht haben
es gibt eine menge von mehrheitlich
positiven tendenzen die ich ganz kurz
zusammenfassen möchte
da ist zum einen der tägliche anstieg
der fallzahlen der sich wirklich
verlangsamt hat im vergleich zur
vorwoche haben wir in dieser woche einen
deutlich geringeren anstieg der
fallzahlen pro tag und wir sehen
natürlich nach wie vor starke regionale
unterschiede
das erwarten wir natürlich auch für die
zukunft die reproduktions zahl die wir
errechnen liegt aktuell im durchschnitt
in deutschland bei 0,7
natürlich gibt es auch hier regionale
unterschiede
aber das zeigt sich dass diese
reproduktions zahl weiter gesunken ist
das heißt dass inzwischen im
durchschnitt momentan aktuell nicht mehr
jede person eine andere person an steckt
also jede person die infiziert ist eine
andere person an steckt aber bundesweit
sind immer noch mehr als 3000 fälle pro
tag gemeldet worden übermittelt worden
von den lokalen gesundheitsämtern an das
robert-koch-institut und wir sehen auch
dass immer mehr menschen die in
medizinischen einrichtungen tätig sind
erkranken
der anteil hat sich zum beispiel
gegenüber der vorwoche rund sechs
prozent erhöht er liegt insgesamt bei
rund 5 prozent von den gesamten
meldezahlen wir sehen leider auch das
was wir erwartet haben dass die zahl der
todesfälle an steigt in dieser woche
hatten wir tatsächlich den bislang
grössten anstieg bei der anzahl der
todesfälle
gestern wurden insgesamt 315 todesfälle
an das robert koch institut übermittelt
damit liegt der anteil der verstorbenen
an allen fällen nun bei 2,9 prozent aber
das ist eben die rate an den offiziell
gemeldeten fällen
wir müssen weiter dafür sorgen dass die
wohlgeraten gruppen gut geschützt werden
wir sehen nämlich insbesondere dort
natürlich die schwersten
krankheitsverläufen das heißt also diese
erste säule die ein der kontakt ketten
nachverfolgung das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiges ziel dass wir weiterfahren
müssen und ich werde gleich zu den tests
noch etwas sagen das ist ein ganz
wichtiges werkzeug wenn wir erfolgreich
sein wollen das heißt also
kontaktpersonen identifizieren würde und
ist weiter zentral bleiben und ein gutes
zwischenergebnis ebenfalls hatte
minister sparen bereits darauf
hingewiesen die ausreichenden
behandlungskapazitäten das ist ein sehr
guter erfolg und bei der derzeitigen
dynamik können wir keine engpässe
prognostizieren das ist die aktuelle
stand und wir hoffen natürlich dass das
so bleibt und ebenfalls eine sehr gute
entwicklung ist dass diese meldungen
seit gestern verpflichtet sind das ist
klasse weil uns dass die chance gibt
eben strategisch patienten wirklich zu
verlegen an orte wo sie optimal versorgt
werden können ganz kurz nur ein paar
zahlen zum stand in deutschland 17
filtern
nur insgesamt rund 134.000 cupid 19
fälle übermittelt worden mehr 3380 mehr
als am vortag
und rund 3800 68 todesfälle die zahlen
gelesen ist auf über 81.000 gestiegen
die produktionszahl hatte schon gesagt
momentan datenstand sechzehnter schulter
0,7 und sie wissen dass sie alle daten
ganz aktuell immer auf der website des
robert-koch-instituts krone.at punkt de
abrufen können bei der aero und dem cdc
gibt es die internationalen daten ganz
kurz ein paar zahlen zu den
krankheitsverläufen so wie wir sie
übermittelt bekommen von den ländern
über die gesundheitsämter von 25 prozent
der übermittelten fälle das sind so rund
2600 der fälle wissen wir dass sie eine
lungenentzündung entwickelt haben und
von 16% der übermittelten fälle wurde
uns eine hospitalisierung übermittelt
und sind rund 17.000 fälle von den rund
104.000 fälle wo wir genügend angaben
dazu haben
ich sagte dass die zahl der todesfälle
in den letzten tagen gestiegen ist das
liegt daran dass die menschen die ihm
vor ein bis zwei wochen erkrankten und
dann schwer erkrankten und auch beatmet
werden dass wir darunter natürlich die
höchsten todesraten haben das liegt
momentan bei den patienten die auf
intensiv liegen bei 130 prozent
und es finden sich natürlich noch
weitere dopingfälle im krankenhaus es
hat mir hier auch froh sind dass wir
noch kapazitäten in den intensivbetten
haben das kurz zur lage ein paar worte
zum testen
die säule eins der bekämpfung ist die
eindämmung eine ganz ganz wichtige säule
wir stehen immer noch am anfang dieser
panini das heißt wir werden noch viele
monate mit diesem virus leben und daher
ist die eindämmung sehr sehr wichtig die
zahlen der die wirklich beeindruckende
zahlen der test kapazitäten wurden auch
schon genannt mehr als 1,73 millionen
test in den letzten wochen
wir können zwischen 730.000 tests pro
woche durchführen und zurzeit haben wir
eine positive rate der tests von rund 9
prozent
das heißt also wir sind der ansicht dass
wir die tests noch strategisch besser
einsetzen können das müssen wir auch in
der zukunft dadurch dass wir so viele
tester patienten haben können wir die
einsatz aber auch ausbauen das heißt
also wir passen ja kontinuierlich das
robert koch institut in zusammenarbeit
mit viel an als taken und passen wir
regelmäßig die test strategie an
wir werden in zukunft natürlich auch
noch vermehrt zum beispiel in
altenheimen pflegeheim testen können um
dort strategisch besser darauf
ausgerichtet zu sein zu verhindern dass
patienten oder zu pflegende infiziert
werden
es werden dort jeden tag quasi neue
strategien erarbeitet wir arbeiten hier
sehr eng zusammen natürlich auch mit dem
kabel frauen die vor kurzem erst eine
neue strategie auch wieder publiziert
haben ein wichtiger schritt ist der dass
dem robert-koch-institut ergebnisse der
labore mittels digitaler schnittstellen
auch ab mai direkt damit also nahezu in
echtzeit über mit in echtzeit
übermittelt werden sollen das ist sehr
wichtig das gibt uns natürlich eine
schnellere reaktionszeit eine bessere
erfassung und wie gesagt wir werden die
test strategien weiter optimieren in
zusammenarbeit mit den gesundheitsämtern
aber auch mit den ärzten und es gibt
eine reihe von konzepten die teilweise
auch regional unterschiedlich gefahren
werden
da sind ja die kassenärztlichen
vereinigung für zuständig zusammenhang
mit dem gesundheitsämter und da gibt es
sehr schöne modelle wo auch immer wieder
voneinander gelernt wird wir tragen das
zusammen und ist eine sehr schöne
entwicklung die sicher dazu führen wird
dass wir gezielt schnell testungen haben
und das nochmal meine damen und herren
das ist der entscheidende punkt nicht
nur wenn es darum geht menschen zu
behandeln und zu identifizieren als co
wird 19 kranke sondern um infekt ketten
zu brechen das ist eine große aufgabe
ausbrüche so schnell wie möglich zu
erkennen und einzelnen danke
haben wir noch die beiden professoren
bei aller komplexität da ich viele
fragen im saal und online angemeldet
bekommen habe würde ich sie bitten
vielleicht die regel so kurz wie möglich
so lange wie nötig zu befolgen
dann hat herr buch jetzt das wort vielen
dank guten tag meine damen und herren
gern halte ich mich auch an diese
vorgaben also die angesprochene dynamik
hat eben auch bei uns im institut dazu
geführt dass wir unsere
schwerpunktsetzungen deutlich verändert
haben so dass eben alles was mit kubik
19 erkrankungen zu tun hat dann auch
entsprechend prioritär bearbeitet wird
das gilt von der wissenschaftlichen
beratung für antragsteller bis hin auch
eben zu den lieferengpass problemen oder
eben auch sonder zulassungen im bereich
medizinprodukte die die situation hat
insgesamt verbessern sollen
wir haben einige erfolgversprechende
therapie ansätze die auch von der whu
empfohlene substanz rem die sie via die
sie auch alle schon gehört haben wird in
deutschland in drei klinischen prüfungen
mittlerweile untersucht zusammen mit dem
ministerium konnten wir auch dafür
sorgen dass in diesen multinationalen
studien relativ viele deutsche zentren
aber auch viele deutsche patienten eben
dann auch eingeschlossen werden
diese studien haben alle eine
unterschiedlich lange laufzeit aber zum
beispiel die zwei dann auch sponsor
gelingt als pharmazeutisches unternehmen
werden in etwa drei monaten dann auch
erste daten dann auch geben und da haben
wir eben zwei große studien hier in
deutschland eine dreieckige studie in
mittelschwer erkrankten patienten wo wir
dann eben auch einfach zwei verschiedene
therapien gegen den standard of care
ohne eine rennserie behandlung
vergleichen und wir haben eine weitere
gleich organisierte studie an acht
deutschen zentren die eben bei schwer
erkrankten dann auch zwei verschiedene
dosierungen dann vergleichen wird von
beiden studien bekommen wir eben in drei
monaten dann auch die ersten ergebnisse
und darauf haben wir uns eben auch
vorbereitet die zulassung würde wenn
erfolgreiche daten
vorliegen daneben auch europäisch
erfolgen und da wir uns sehr eingesetzt
das bva experten als rapport höher also
die europäische bewertung dann auch für
die europäische zulassungsbehörde von
unseren experten durchgeführt wird
zusammen für den qualitäts bad mit
österreichischen kollegen
wir haben eine dritte studie mit fremde
sie wir die ja auch multi centris
multinational durchgeführt wird sie wird
organisiert von amerikanischen zentren
und anthony fauci ist einer der
prinzipiellen dann auch studienleiter
für diese studie auch hier sind eben
vier zentren in deutschland beteiligt
und auch dort werden zwischen ergebnisse
in wenigen monaten dann auch vorliegen
wichtig ist mir auch zu erwähnen
chloroquin für toxikologie und
kolloquien die in der öffentlichkeit
sehr sehr stark diskutiert werden laufen
auch strategische studien in deutschland
um eben auch verschiedene dosen dort zu
vergleichen
es ist aber auch hier ein gutes beispiel
klar zu machen wir dürfen keine
standards absenken proxy chloroquin wird
eingesetzt aber sie haben jetzt auch
über nebenwirkungen todesfälle in
manchen ländern gehört wo patienten sich
diese arzneimittel dann über die
apotheke selber besorgt und
unkontrolliert eingenommen haben
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir all
diese arzneimittel in den klinischen
prüfungen auf wirksamkeit auf
unbedenklichkeit untersuchen
und da sind wir eben jetzt in
deutschland auch auf einem sehr guten
weg so dass wir da auch für sicherheit
dann auch sorgen können
und das ist etwas was mir auch ganz
wichtig ist in den medien oder auch wir
bekommen sehr viele anfragen das kann ja
wohl nicht sein dass das befahren jetzt
auch in einer solchen krise standards
absenkt und vielleicht die patienten
dann erhöhten risiken aussetzt das ist
nicht der fall
es wird keinerlei standard abgesenkt
sondern wir setzen einfach mehr personal
parallel an diese klinischen prüfungen
und wir haben dann eben auch die
möglichkeiten wenn es klare
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse gibt
dann zum beispiel auch beschleunigt
zuzulassen da machen wir gar keine
sonderregelung sondern dass es alles
jetzt schon auch in den laufenden
verfahren so möglich eine besondere
rolle hatten wir auch im bereich
medizinprodukte dort haben wir über die
sonder zulassungen für nicht ce
gekennzeichnete masken oder auch
testverfahren dann diese option anstelle
der benannten stellen in deutschland das
zu tun da haben wir eben seit anfang
märz 220 anträge bekommen jeden tag
kommen mittlerweile etwa 30 dazu und
zwei drittel dieser anträge befasst sie
sich zum beispiel jetzt in der ersten
phase mit der zulassung von dann masken
und da haben wir eben auch sehr viele
anträge bescheiden können auch hier
werden keine standards standards
abgesenkt da haben wir auch checklisten
zur verfügung also auch diese masken die
ins land hinein kommen wird prüfungen
unterzogen und können daneben adäquat im
medizinischen bereich eingesetzt werden
vielen dank danke dafür herzig bitte der
vielen dank meine damen und herren wer
gestern die letzte talkshow zum thema
gesehen hat hat erlebt wie drosten
meinte dass in stoffe und therapeutika
träume wären
ich kann ihnen sagen wir träumen nicht
sondern wir arbeiten da waren dass das
wirklichkeit wird
ich kann ihnen hier sagen dass wir im
bereich der therapeutischer einmal die
small molecule chemischen wirkstoffe
haben die direkt das virus und seine
vermehrung in der zelle haben dessen der
zuständigkeit vom bv wir haben aber zwei
weitere
möglichkeiten im repertoire gegen die
krankheit vorzugehen
das sind einmal rekonvaleszent plasma
und die immobilie dann geht es darum
dass bei genesenen im blut im plasma
antikörper zu finden sind die direkt das
virus neutralisieren können und auf
diese weise verhindern dass nach einmal
infizierter zellen die neu gebildeten
vieren hocken und diese möglichkeit ist
inzwischen ins auge gefasst wir haben
dazu eine entsprechende klinische
prüfung mit rekonvaleszent entlassung
eines größeren deutschen und
universitäts konzert zusammen im
blutspendedienst genehmigen können und
weitere genehmigungsanträge liegen an
hier haben wir auch noch eine von
beratungen in den letzten zwei wochen
durchführen können und wir werden
weitere anträge haben genauso geht es
mit dem monoklonalen antikörpern sie
erinnern sich vielleicht in der regular
season hatten wir am schluss ein
antikörper cocktail der tatsächlich
erleichterung gebracht hat und die
krankheit gezielt bahnen und auch hier
gibt es nur reihe von ansätzen dazu ganz
wichtig ist auch dass wir nicht nur das
virus zu bekämpfen sondern seine
auswirkung und das heißt die
überschießende immunreaktionen
beispielsweise kann gedämpft werden
hier gibt es ermutigen der einzelfall
berichte die davon reden dass bestimmte
antikörper direkt zur versenkung führen
oder sogar zu besseren
sauerstoffsättigung im blut
allerdings ist wichtig ihnen zu sagen es
gibt im moment sehr viele ansätze die
auch bei uns vorgetragen werden
hier müssen wir unterscheiden
ernstzunehmende von ansätzen die keine
plausible prothese am 2
der wichtige punkt ist dass wir auf
aussagekräftigen untersuchungen im
rahmen klinischer prüfung hinweisen
denn die gesamtheit dieser ansätze das
brauchen wir bis verwiesen werden und
dann wirklich den patienten helfen zu
können
ich gehe das nächste thema ein das ist
das thema der impfstoffe dass sie sicher
interessieren wird auch hier ist es so
dass wichtig ist dass wir kreative
impfstoffe brauchen und dass diese
impfstoffe spezifisch sind
und gegen das virus zu werden denn es
gibt da durchaus auch unspezifisch
einsätze und dann solchen stoff wie er
ganz sicher der game changer auch hier
gilt wir müssen impfstoffe haben die
verträglich sind und die wirksam sind
wir können reihe von maßnahmen ergreifen
aufgrund unserer regulatorischen
flexibilität und der expertise der leute
im paul-ehrlich-institut dass wir
bestimmte phasen der klinischen prüfung
komprimieren und gezielt auf klinische
prüfung hinführen genau das passiert
momentan aber zwei dinge sind wichtig
bei der stoffentwicklung nicht die
zulassung dauert lange sondern die
entwicklung dauert lange das heißt es
müssen gewisse labor untersuchungen
vorgenommen werden um theoretische
riesige abzuklären
es müssen gleichzeitig klinische
prüfungen laufen um sicher zu sein dass
die impfstoffe ihr ziel erreichen
nämlich spezifisch wirksam zu sein aber
auch verträglich und sicher sind sie
wissen dass wir etwa 50 bis 60 im stoff
projekte weltweit laufen haben das heißt
hier ist ein globaler erfurt im gange
wir haben vier klinische prüfung
weltweit die begonnen wurden dass es die
ära von moderner in den usa inovio einen
dna impfstoff und zwei vector impfstoffe
auf basis von adenovirus in china und in
uk und ich kann ihnen ankündigen dass
wir in kürze auch in deutschland dem
beginn einer ersten klinischen prüfung
haben werden
und ich bin sicher dass wir auch im
laufe des jahres noch weitere klinische
prüfung haben werden in deutschland und
da handelt es sich ebenfalls um zwei
ehrenabend 2 vector impfstoff die
entsprechenden verfahren laufen und da
kann jetzt kann ich detaillierter
ausgeben
ich bin sehr glücklich dass wir von
seinen bmw und bmws die richtigen
projektfinanzierungen laufen haben war
cpi über andere gezielte förderung dass
wir aber auch an
rahmenbedingungen an der schaffung
günstiger umstände für die
impfstoffentwicklung gemeinsamen
arbeiten dass die akademischen
industrien entwickler den job machen die
richtigen kandidaten impfstoffe jetzt zu
entwickeln und hoffentlich positiv und
mit gutem ausgang prüfen
und wir führen als policy institute die
entwicklung gezielt und beschleunigt in
die klinische prüfung und versuchen auf
die reihe der klinischen produkten zu
fokussieren auf die wirklich
essentiellen prüfung wenn sie näheres
wissen wollen auch in der nächsten woche
www.zeit.de ist die quelle wo sie die
information bekommen
wir werden natürlich dann wenn es um die
impfstoffe geht mehrere impfstoffe
brauchen denn sie können sich vorstellen
dass ein hersteller den bedarf der da
sein wird nicht erfüllen wird können wir
brauchen noch mehrere sorten von
impfstoffen denn die haben
unterschiedliche eigenschaften das ist
jetzt schon abzusehen
und wir werden aber versuchen dass wir
insgesamt durch modalität wie absturz
übernahme vielleicht bewogen wird vom
bund und ähnliches zu schnell klinischen
prüfungen und schnell unten kommen
werden als bisher ich bin also ganz
zuversichtlich dass wir schon in
nächster zeit hier fortschritte zeigen
werden auch in deutschland und ich
glaube wir können alle stolz sein dass
oft mit der vorarbeiten wir in
deutschland nahe von firmen haben und
biotech-unternehmen und akademische
entwickler die hier ganz vorne am ball
sind und die sehr schnell ihre
entwicklung in die klinische prüfung
einbringen vielen dank
danke dafür den con leche ihren fragen
ich habe online auf eine reihe von
fragen da sind auch stichworte masken
apps allgemein geht es um die
einschränkungen ich würde versuchen das
ein bisschen thematisch zu bündeln und
fange hier aber im saal an hat herr
kocht die erste frage wie viele masken
stehen für die normalbevölkerung im
anblick auf dem deutschen markt zur
verfügung
an der pro woche und wann wird der
bedarf in diesem bereich gedeckt sein
also jetzt nicht nur spezielle masken
für die kranken weise sondern auch für
die normalen bürger und bürgerinnen wenn
es um medizinische schutzmasken geht
also insbesondere auch die ffg zwei
masken geht es hier ja vor allem darum
jetzt in einem ersten schritt
sicherzustellen dass alle im
gesundheits- und pflegewesen tätigen
ausreichend ausgestattet und das ist
auch der auftrag den der beschaffung
start beim bundesministerium für
gesundheit hat für das gesundheitswesen
die entsprechenden schutzmasken zu
sorgen wenn es um die frage des der
alltags massen geht die auch in dem
beschluss der ministerpräsidenten mit
der bundeskanzlerin am mittwoch
adressiert worden sind mit einer
dringlichen empfehlung einem masken
gebot etwa für den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr u bahn oder bus bahn
dann sind das er vor allem textile
masken umgeht wird auch geht und gehen
kann und so wie meine wahrnehmung ist
das ist ja nichts was der bund zentral
beschafft ist aber der textilindustrie
der textileinzelhandel der einzelhandel
insgesamt sowohl online wäre in dem was
vor ort verfügbar ist auf dem weg die
kapazitäten enorm zu erhöhen
mein eindruck ist dass diese alltags
masten jetzt habe ich allein auf dem weg
vom ministerium er hin zu ihnen gemerkt
er tatsächlich immer mehr verbreitung
und akzeptanz finden
zahlen dazu haben sie nicht also wie
viele beispielsweise op masken die ja
besser sind als irgendwelche bücher die
man sich vors gesicht hängt in apotheken
zu kaufen sind also welche mengen darf
voran sind und wie die steigen und man
damit der bedarf gedeckt ist wir haben
jenseits dessen was der bund geschafft
keine abschließende übersicht über die
zahl der op masken in deutschland weil
es natürlich so ist das ja alle also der
apotheken der großhandel die
krankenhäuser viele andere institutionen
masken beschaffen im übrigen zum teil ja
auch produzieren hier in deutschland und
in
oper und wir keine kontrolle wie bei
anderen waren des täglichen verkehrs
auch nicht darüber haben wie viele nach
deutschland gelangen was ich ihnen sagen
kann ist die zahl die wir seitens des
bundes geschaffen
die habe ich gerade für diese woche
allein genannt dass wir nach deutschland
gebracht haben aber ich sage noch einmal
unserer hauptzielrichtung ist in diesem
moment
und so ist auch der ausführliche auftrag
für das gesundheitswesen eine
ausreichende zahl von medizinischen
schutzmasken zu besorgen
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich eine
debatte darüber wie wir beim thema
arbeitsschutz ist die zweite kategorie
ausreichend schutz material und masten
erhaben und das dritte sind die gerade
von mir angesprochenen alltags masse
dann ergänzt sich dazu mal eine frage
die uns online zug gestellt wurde von
simon schütz bild fragt die stadt jena
hat eine masken pflicht eingeführt und
gibt es seit acht tagen keine einzige
neue infektion sollte das jenaer modell
dann nicht auf deutschland über weiter
werden statt ein massengebet er eine
massen pflicht mein eindruck ist dass
meisten bürgerinnen und bürger sehr
verantwortlich mit der momentanen lage
umgehen und die freiheit und eben auch
der hinweis auf ein massen geburt genau
so nutzen dass sie nämlich zum schutz
von anderen das ist ja das wichtige bei
den alltags masken vor allem auch in die
partikel die wir alle beim sprechen
wurde auch beim niesen ausströmen
entsprechend zu reduzieren dass immer
mehr diese tatsächlich tragen und ich
abschließend und grundsätzlich er auch
auf freiheit einsicht mitmachen
akzeptanz durch auch überzeugen mit
argumenten setzte weil aller erfahrung
nach gebote tatsächlich auch er
unterstützung mit sich bringt als
verpflichtungen die dann auch
möglicherweise wieder andere fragen mit
sich bringen und ich würde doch einfach
mal empfehlen dass wir jetzt mit der
entwicklung die wir haben dieser tage
mit wie ich es jedenfalls war neben
einer steigenden zahl von bürgerinnen
und
die im alltag beim einkaufen im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr
tatsächlich diese alltags masken nutzen
dass wir jetzt auch einfach diese
entwicklung mal die nächsten tage
abwarten und dann darüber beraten wie
wir damit dann weiter auch umgehen was
übrigens ganz ganz wichtig ist es der
richtige gebrauch
sonst ist nämlich das risiko der maske
größer als der nicht maske sie muss
natürlich auch gewaschen werden bei der
entsprechenden temperatur und sie muss
auch so auf und ab gesetzt werden dass
tatsächlich dadurch das infektionsrisiko
nicht erhöht wird da mögen einige hier
im raum schmunzeln
das ist aber ein sehr sehr wichtiger
punkt nicht richtig genutzt
masken auch alltags masken erhöhen das
risiko und deswegen müssen wir alle
gemeinsam und das sagt auch der minister
aus eigener erfahrung den richtigen
umgang mit masken jeden tag
offensichtlich leer
die nächste frage ludwig ja wir haben ja
gesagt dass die zwischenbilanz ziehen
und ganz am anfang dieser krise als eben
die es noch nicht klar war dass eine
quelle der infektionen in italien sein
könnte hatte man sich auf china
konzentriert und ich frage mich wenn sie
jetzt lehren aus dem ziel die gehandelt
wurde würden sie rückblickend
einreisekontrollen stärker machen gibt
es etwas was ich jetzt schon gelernt
haben
bei einem möglichen neuen virus in der
zukunft die von anfang an regio sachen
und anna lena selbst wenn die zahlen
positiv sind in deutschland befinden wir
uns ja im umkreis von von anderen
ländern wo überall auch
ausbruchsgeschehen das wie würden sie
denn sagen
wie wäre ihr perspektive auf eine
grenzöffnung oder überhaupt auf reife
absehbar aller bohrungen zuerst einmal
war es ja auch international übrigens
auch internationalen
gesundheitsorganisationen empfehlung den
reiseverkehr tatsächlich nicht übermäßig
einzuschränken aus heutiger sicht würde
man an manchen stellen sicherlich anders
handeln aber wissen sie dass heute ich
bin ja immer ganz neidisch auf
diejenigen die die heute schon immer
alles gewusst haben sondern wir haben
von anfang an gesagt wir sind in einer
dynamischen situation wir können immer
nur nach dem stand des wissens an dem
jeweiligen tag der entscheidung
entscheidung treffen
und das hat in sich immer auch das
risiko dass wir im nachhinein
feststellen müssen durch neue
erkenntnisse durch neue entwicklungen
dass man vielleicht im nachhinein mit
anderem wissen anders entschieden hätte
das halte ich aber für einen relativ
normalen umstand in einer solchen krise
mit einem solchen virus das völlig
neuartig ist wenn wir übrigens auch was
gelernt haben wir international mit
ländern die weltgesundheitsorganisation
als organisation und als koordiniere und
kooperationspartner ist sehr sehr
wichtig dass dann aber auch alle länder
die mitglied dieser
weltgesundheitsorganisation sind dann
sehr sehr frühzeitig wenn sie einen
ausbruch eines neuen virus haben alle
informationen zur verfügung stellen
sollten auch das ist ohne zweifel eine
lesson learned das nur dann wenn die
weltgemeinschaft sehr sehr frühzeitig
alle informationen die verfügbar sind
über ein solches virus auch von den
ländern in dem es zuerst ausbricht
bekommt können wir auch alle gemeinsam
mit diesen informationen dann besser
agieren ja zu ihrer frage kurz ist ist
ja seit einiger zeit eine quarantäne
angeordnet für diejenigen die aus dem
ausland einreisen
eine zweiwöchige quarantäne das ist
sicher eine gute maßnahme und meines
wissens ist nie gilt die zunächst einmal
für längere zeit das macht auch der
immer wieder überprüft wie sich die
epidemiologische situation entwickelt
übrigens weise die quarantäne 2000 als
ich den hinweis gegeben habe und wir uns
das als bundesministerium für gesundheit
sehr stark auch in den sozialen medien
und in den medien beworben haben und
aufgefordert haben die winterurlaubs
reiserückkehrer sollen zwei wochen zu
hause bleiben weiß ich noch wie ich
kritisiert worden bin für diese aussage
also es ist ja nicht so als wären wir
nicht alle gemeinsam in einem
dynamischen lernprozess ich ergänze dazu
auch noch mal fragen die uns online
zugestellt wurden eine nachfrage von
sascha meyer dpa an herrn wieder den
stand welchen zeitraum spiegelt der
aktuelle reproduktions wert wieder den
ganz aktuellen oder einige tage
zurückliegenden sind effekte der
osterfeiertage schon enthalten und dann
noch mal eine frage des kollegen schutz
von b die ansteckungsrate ist doch 0,7
gesunken wäre das schon am mittwoch
bekannt gewesen hätte man dann ja
lockerungen beschließen können also die
berechnung wir haben diese
berechnungsmethode ja schon einmal
vorgestellt wir haben sie auch schon
mehrfach publiziert es gibt eine
publikation im epidemiologischen
bulletin wo man sich die methodik noch
mal genauer anschauen kann
wir wissen ja dass die reinen meldezahl
natürlich nicht das gesamte bild dagegen
dass es dort verzerrungen gibt dass es
zeit für züge gibt weshalb wir schon
länger natürlich an methoden arbeiten
auch zusammen mit internationalen
kolleginnen und kollegen wie wir das
besser einschätzen können wir haben das
know casting gewählt eine methode wo wir
unter einberechnung von zeitverzögerung
von beginn der krankheit von
behandlungszeiten von dauer der
krankheit der inklusive der
inkubationszeit halt bestimmte
modellierungen durchführen
dieser er null wert berechnet sich jeden
tag neu
der umfasst aber nicht die letzten vier
tage weil doch zu viele ungenauigkeiten
sind das heißt also wir rechnen quasi
mal rund vier tage zurück und das ist
die die berechnung des korps die sehen
ja das war ungefähr sagt die
23 wer immer so um die 1 rum waren und
wir sehen jetzt eben dass wir zum ersten
mal unter die 1 gekommen sind ob das
stabil bleibt werden wir sehen
das ist wirklich mir immer wichtig zu
sagen wir stehen
dieses virus ist ja in unserem land es
bleibt ja auch in unserem land das heißt
also es kann ja jederzeit wieder zu
infektionen kommen
das ist ja keine tilgung wir haben eine
erste welle ganz gut überstanden denke
ich das ist wirklich durch eine
gemeinsame anstrengung von der
gesellschaft geschehen
aber das kann sich jederzeit ändern also
man darf diesen wert natürlich nicht
überbewerten es ist immer eine
momentaufnahme und dieser dieser wert
werden wir sehen aber stabil bleibt ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen aber das ist
noch eine spekulation kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass nur wegen dieses wertes
wichtiger entschlüsse plötzlich anders
ausfallen es ist ein wert und wir haben
auch immer wieder betont ist wirklich
wichtig wir haben eine menge kennzahlen
also das ist ja die vor wir hätten ein r
von 1 und werden jeden tag 50.000 fälle
ja also das hieß denn dann wäre ja
einfach die absolute fallzahl zu hoch
das heißt der r1 alleine macht es
natürlich nicht sondern es kommt darauf
an dass wir auch nur eine bestimmte
fallzahl haben pro tag die wir
beherrschen können vom gesundheitssystem
es kommt auch auf instanzen an auf
häufigkeiten in bestimmten gruppen von
bevölkerung also der wert alleine ist
ein wichtige maßzahl aber er ist sicher
nicht die einzige zahl auf die wir uns
berufen dürfen und zudem auch das normal
es gibt natürlich nach wie vor regionen
in deutschland wo er deutlich über das
ist regional unterschiedlich
dann machen wir mit der nächsten frage
im saal weiter die kollegin lisa braun
presseagentur gesundheit ich habe eine
frage herr professor bruch herr
professor bruch zu einer globalisierten
arzneimittel wirtschaft gehören ja auch
immer schwierigkeiten in der lieferkette
das kennen wir aus der vergangenheit
schon vor corona jetzt haben wir nicht
nur corona was erheblich die
lieferketten belastet sondern wir haben
auch noch die afrikanische schweinepest
über die redet überhaupt keiner heparin
wird daraus gewonnen wird steht jetzt
schon mal hat der afrikanischen
schweinepest sozusagen vor brandenburg
können sie vielleicht noch einmal
bewerten wie die lief belieferung von
arznei
insbesondere notfall arzneimitteln in
zukunft aussehen wird die eu ministerin
hat dazu heute schon deutlich ist brief
losgelassen mit einer ganzen reihe von
medikamenten die wir demnächst
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so ohne
weiteres haben werden die nächste frage
noch ganz schnell an den spanier
minister sparen wenn sie davon sprechen
dass wir multinationale beteiligungen
haben und alle jetzt wie wild versuchen
einen den retten den impfstoff zu
entwickeln was gilt dann hinterher bei
der allokation frage da wo das
arzneimittel spricht der impfstoff
produziert wird in dem land in europa
oder in deutschland oder gilt america
first ich meine das ist ja banal wir
wissen wer zuerst das kriegt das sind
sicherlich ärztliche berufspolitische
berufe und wohlhabende gruppen
aber die frage ist eher welches land hat
wo den finger drauf dann gibt es ja
einen ganz knallharten verteilungskampf
und vielleicht haben sie auch mit den
firmen schon darüber geredet es gibt ja
jetzt große zusammenspiel frage
irgendwann beenden ja jetzt bei gsk
hannover haben sich zusammengeschlossen
beispielsweise wird mit denen schon
gesprochen wo die demnächst an
produzieren wollen
danke ich bin ja die liebe lieferengpass
problematik begleitet uns in der tat
seit langen wir sind froh dass wir eben
nur fix zu den lieferengpässen haben
haben speziell zum thema corona jetzt
auch mit dem bmw zusammen eine task
force gebildet die speziell auch diese
problematik der intensiv arzneimittel
dann auch in angriff genommen hat wir
haben sehr mit dem register jetzt auch
schon zusammengearbeitet was der
minister erwähnt hat mit dem die wii was
brauchen wir für die intensivbetten die
wir jetzt auch aufgebaut haben dann hat
man intensiv arzneimitteln da haben wir
berücksichtigt dass die kobik patienten
länger beatmet werden dass hier auch
mehr bedarf an diesen intensiv
arzneimitteln haben wir haben aber auch
ein vierteljahr in deutschland jetzt
schon hinter uns wo wir auch operationen
reduziert haben das heißt die großen
kliniken sind im moment noch sehr gut
bevorratet
mit all diesen intensiv arzneimitteln es
gibt regionale unterschiede da wo eben
viele krankenhäuser jetzt schon sehr
stark betroffen waren gibt es den ein
oder anderen engpass noch keinen
versorgungsengpass aber es gibt einen
engpass und den wollen wir über die task
force ist aber auch managen
wir haben regionen in deutschland wo die
krankenhäuser eben sehr wenig belegt
sind auch die intensivstationen keinen
verbrauch haben
da wollen wir halt dann jetzt nicht die
patienten verlegen sondern die
arzneimittel sollen dann dorthin wo sie
dann auch gebraucht werden das zeichnet
sich ab dass wir das sehr gut in den
griff bekommen und von unserer seite tun
wir auch alles dafür zum beispiel
propofol ist ja ein arzneimittel was da
immer wieder genannt wird und wichtig
ist was auch länger im eng passt ist da
haben wir jetzt auch fresenius zum
beispiel erlaubt dann auch größere
ampullen auch abzufüllen was logistisch
eine erhebliche umsatzsteigerung dann in
der herstellung auch ermöglicht ohne
dass wir dabei eben auch daneben
qualitätseinbußen hinnehmen alle
maßnahmen werden dann eben auch
entsprechend abgestimmt und damit haben
wir das in deutschland im moment gut im
griff
heparin haben wir auch da sehr eng im
fokus zumal eben auch die neigung zu
thrombosen und embolien gerade weil den
coffee patienten überraschend war so
dass auch da der bedarf deutlich höher
ist und noch da sind wir im moment gut
bevorratet
zur frage wer mit zwei dimensionen das
eine ist die frage der verteilung
möglicherweise in deutschland sie haben
schon hinweise gegeben wir haben auch
die impfkommission beim robert koch
institut schon gebeten sich jetzt schon
gedanken darüber zu machen wie man in
welcher reihenfolge in welcher priorität
man in deutschland impfen würde bei
einem ja nicht gleich für alle zur
verfügung stehenden impfstoff dass die
kriterien noch folgen und die sollen
natürlich frühzeitig auch erarbeitet
sein
das gleiche gilt für die frage natürlich
der weltweiten lage
wir sind grundsätzlich sehr sehr
zurückhaltend was beschränkungen angeht
haben sie auch immer nur an einer stelle
ja bis jetzt beim thema schutzmasken
zeitlich sehr verkürzt genutzt um eine
aktenlage entgegenzuwirken weil wir so
abhängig sind voneinander das spüren wir
ja jeden tag in den lieferketten dass
jede beschränkung immer auch eine
folgewirkung hat mein eindruck ist dass
das fehler der länder und partnerländer
auf der welt auch verinnerlicht haben
mittlerweile was die frage der
produktionskapazitäten angeht bei
impfstoffen nehme ich wahr dass die
pharmazeutische industrie insgesamt und
zwar in deutschland in europa darüber
hinaus sich darauf vorbereitet dass auch
sehr schnell
die produktionskapazitäten in
kooperation hochgefahren werden können
das wird auch eine zeit dauern aber mein
eindruck ist dass es da auch sehr große
kooperation ergibt die wir natürlich
auch befördern und begleiten und
gleichzeitig wollen wir möglich machen
auch durch entsprechende
abnahmegarantien dass diejenigen die
jetzt am impfstoffforschung wer
professor psychosekte es dargestellt hat
jetzt auch schon parallel beginnen
können produktionskapazitäten aufzubauen
der normale folge ist eigentlich dass du
erst richtig anfängt
produktionskapazitäten aufzubauen und es
sozusagen finale zugelassen ist und wir
versuchen das jetzt möglich zu machen
auch durch eine finanzielle begleitung
bei denjenigen die in deutschland
entsprechend tätig sind dass sie
parallelen produktionskapazitäten
aufbauen damit dann eben auch schnell
begonnen werden kann
in deutschland aufbauen aber wir wollen
nicht nur für deutschland produzieren
eben hat auch die situation in kliniken
angesprochen wurde was ich mal drei
fragen online zusammen da fragt der
kollege philipp sandmann von rtl und n
tv
herrn sparen die notaufnahmen sind gut
aufgestellt aber keiner kommt das ist
unwirtschaftlich und unsinnig manch eine
klinik geht sogar in kurzarbeit wie
sehen sie das problem
ist da was muss passieren gerd joachim
von verlor von phoenix hat noch
ergänzend die frage dazu wie wird der
bund das abfedern verweist auch auf
finanzielle schieflage von kliniken und
der kollege sascha meyer von dpa afx
ragt noch wieviel sicherheitsreserve an
intensivbetten für corona patienten muss
weiter bleiben also zum ersten jahr mir
eine finanzielle abfederung für die
kliniken sehr schnell im bundestag und
bundesrat beschlossen im märz kurz nach
der entscheidung auch bette neben frei
zu machen um vorzubereiten wo er
erstmalig auch für freie betten sehr
je nachdem welche art klinik aber für
einige schon auch sehr großzügig
finanziert wird einige sagen es muss
mehr sein wir haben ein expertenbeirat
der auch dieser tage eingesetzt wird
zwischen krankenhäusern krankenkassen
wissenschaft der uns in den nächsten
wochen auch noch mal sagen soll wo wir
nachsteuern müssen weil wir wollen
natürlich liquidität sichern in den
kliniken dass sie auch stabil bleiben
und deswegen die instrumente dazu auch
immer nach steuern dazu gehört auch die
frage der notaufnahme und der
intensivstation was mich beschäftigt und
umtreibt das habe ich vorhin gesagt ich
schon auch die frage wo denn die not
patienten hin sind wenn wir eben ärzte
notärzte berichten dass die zahl der
herzinfarkte und schlaganfälle die in
den krankenhäusern ankommen zurückgeht
dann muss uns ja schon die frage
beschäftigen was ist da eigentlich wer
steckt dahinter und die beschäftigt und
sehr und wir versuchen das eben auch mit
den mediziner natürlich dem nachzugehen
und gleichzeitig auch das signal an die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu senden
sind wir nehmen wahr dass es zum teil
eine sorgende zurückhaltung gibt eben
auch im moment in eine klinik zu gehen
aus sorge möglicherweise vor einer
infektion oder andere mehr zu sagen wenn
da ein notfall ist dann bitte unbedingt
auch natürlich die dafür zur verfügung
stehenden ressourcen des
gesundheitswesens nutzen und auf die
eigene gesundheit achten das ist ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir die da die balance
jetzt miteinander finden
aus dieser ersten dynamik heraus und den
maßnahmen die wir präventiv getroffen
haben jetzt eine neue normalität eben
auch für den kreis
house betrieb zu finden auch regional zu
finden mit einer klugen vorhersage
welche intensiv kapazitäten ich habe
gerade gesagt für den start aus meiner
sicht aber es ist erst mal pauschal 25
bis 30 prozent für cupid 19 patienten
frei halten und das dann immer weiter
von steuern zu können auch regional über
unser intensiv register das ist jedes
krankenhaus man weiß ja nach nach zehn
hüft-op es da gibt es ja auch
erfahrungswerte wie viele intensiv
medizin sich daraus in der folge
möglicherweise für zwei drei tage ergibt
das kann man ja kann man ja steuern
wenn wir das besser steuern können wir
tatsächlich auch besser das ist das ziel
über die nächsten wochen
die kapazitäten planen und das signal an
alle anderen senden dass die behandlung
die nötig sind natürlich auch gemacht
werden sollen und gemacht werden müssen
aber als er um die gesundheit aller geht
mit allen erkrankungen in deutschland
und deswegen eben auch die notaufnahmen
eine sehr wichtige rolle weiterhin
spielen und auch finanziell dann
abgesichert werden weiter geht es mit
fragen aus dem saal hat die nächste
anfang an den wähler sie haben jetzt ja
eine ganze reihe ziele ich sag mal
erreicht also jedenfalls alle die ich
jetzt so kannte sind eigentlich erreicht
wir sind jetzt bei 0,7 reproduktionsrate
soll die jetzt noch weiter sinken also
haben sie neue ziele und sind jan
überhaupt sinnvoll war eine gewisse
infektion ist ja wahrscheinlich ganz gut
da können sie ja mal sagen wie was sie
sich da vornehmen und frage nochmals
sparen einmal zu dieser abstand app
können sie zu machen stand jetzt
zwischen land wo ist man daran kann man
damit rechnen dass die einsatzfähig ist
und zu den intensivbetten muss man nicht
weit auch sagen man hätte vielleicht
frankreich und italien mehr helfen
können oder kann man das auch noch kommt
zuerst die ziele tatsächlich ist unser
ziel noch nicht erreicht das ist ja
nicht zum einen ist ja nicht dauerhaft
wir haben wenn momentan stand von diesem
r
und wir wollen natürlich dauerhaft dass
es so bleibt das ist ein wichtiges ziel
und mein 0,7 oder also unter 1 unter 1
stabil unter 1 das wäre unser wunsch
wenn uns das gelingt das ist das ziel
was wir
angestrebt haben und ich meine wir
dürfen ja immer nicht vergessen dafür
sind ja eine menge anstrengungen
unternommen worden dass das ist ja klar
das heißt also wenn die maßnahmen dann
schrittweise gelockert werden müssen
natürlich diese ziele im auge behalten
und und das heißt sie zu verteidigen ja
so sehe ich das
zu der frage der app noch mal auch zum
hintergrund das ist ja auch das was er
professor wähler gerade gesagt hat das
ganz ganz wichtige mit diesem virus auf
seiner infektiosität ist dass wir wenn
jemand als infiziert festgestellt wird
durch einen test sehr schnell die
kontakte der nächsten der letzten tage
die näheren kontakt auch identifizieren
können benachrichtigen können auch
isoliert werden können quarantäne
gebracht werden könnten das passiert im
moment vornehmlich und ausschließlich
händisch sozusagen durch durch abfrage
nachfrage derjenige muss sich auch sehr
gut erinnern können erstmal alle
kontakte sie können ja mal überlegen und
sie für die letzten zehn tage nach osten
mit wenig mehr als zehn minuten
verbracht haben das ist schon immer eine
fehlerquote und die zweite ist eben die
kapazitäten die personellen ressourcen
da hinterher zu telefonieren zu besuchen
gespräche zu führen an ob nun
auszustellen und die idee ist dass eine
app dabei eben helfen kann das deutlich
schneller und effizienter zu machen so
die es in der entwicklung ja das was wir
im hauptfokus haben die app insbesondere
auch auf basis der bluetooth-technologie
das zu machen als freiwilliges angebot
ganz wichtig sind die drei parameter das
eine ist datensicherheit
das muss er eine sichere app sein weil
es um auf sensible daten geht was hacken
zugriff von andern und anderes an geht
es geht um darin schutz wo dann der
datenschutzbeauftragte natürlich auch zu
involvieren ist auch das konzept muss
natürlich passen in unsere
datenschutzrechtlichen regelungen und es
geht um das epidemiologische konzept die
frage eben was genau brauchen wir denn
als parameter für abstand und zeit der
nähe sind all diese drei parameter
werden mit den drei zuständigen behörden
bsi für die datensicherheit lkw für die
epidemiologie und der datenschutz
beauftragte für den datenschutz und dem
konsortium in der federführung von
fraunhofer entwickelt und bearbeitet ich
würde sagen aus heutiger sicht sind eher
vier wochen als zwei wochen bis wir
tatsächlich dann eine haben die auch all
diese anforderungen voll erfüllt weil
wir müssen natürlich gerade bei
datenschutz und datensicherheit können
wir keine großen kompromisse machen
dann müssen die dinge am ende auch
stimmen bei der intensivmedizin ich habe
ja intensiven austausch auch mit meinen
kollegen etwa aus italien spanien
frankreich und wir haben ja und ich bin
ich auch sehr dankbar für auch
bundesländer die kliniken patienten aus
diesen ländern zur behandlung nach
deutschland auch genommen was auch mit
großer dankbarkeit aufgenommen worden
ist in diesen in diesen ländern mussten
aber gleichzeitig ja auch nicht wie die
entwicklung bei uns in deutschland sein
wird das ist ja für uns alle auch immer
ein schwieriger spagat wie man ja auch
in der reaktion der bevölkerung merkt wo
es ja auf diese angebote zweierlei sehr
unterschiedliche reaktionen gegeben hat
aus heutiger sicht und ich habe mir auch
vorgenommen mit den kollegen
gesundheitsminister mit ich nachher auch
eine telefonkonferenz habe eine reguläre
unter anderem darüber zu reden ob und in
welchem umfang wir angesichts der lage
in der wir sind auch ein angebot an
unsere europäischen nachbarn machen
können jetzt für die nächsten wochen
zusätzliche patienten zu nehmen um dann
anschließend auch mit den kollegen zu
sprechen welchen bedarf ist dann ergibt
wir sind jetzt in der lage mit dem
wissen darum wie die dynamik bei uns im
moment im land ist stand heute
jedenfalls sicherlich auch darüber
hinaus über das bisher schon gemacht
auch den nachbarländern zu helfen mein
eindruck ist aber auch dass jede anfrage
nach unterstützung und hilfe und
verlegung bis jetzt auch entsprechend
halt beantwortet werden können wir
hatten noch ungefähr eine viertelstunde
ein
reihe von fragen daher mit der bitte um
kurze fragen und antworten dass wir
möglichst schnell möglichst viele noch
dran nehmen können
das gilt auch für die online kollegen
weiß nicht ob wir noch alle schaffen
aber die nächste frage frau wolf im saal
eine frage zuerst an sparen
diese positive entwicklung wurde jetzt
mehrfach beschrieben sie sprachen auch
davon dass es videos beherrschbar sei
jetzt wenn sie vor diesem hintergrund
als problematisch jetzt weiterhin hohe
akzeptanz für die doch noch
weitergehende beschränkungen mit
zugewinnen in der bevölkerung also wird
es schwieriger das zu erklären auch vor
dem hintergrund einer rechtfertigung von
brechts einschnitten die nach wie vor
die genau wie vor erleben und eine frage
an kein bieler
wie hat sich denn ihre einschätzung zu
den dunkelsten verändert die ja einfach
einen wichtigen hinweis über den verlauf
und und und den zustand der pandemie
geben also können sie momentan auch eine
aktuelle einschätzung dazu beziffern
ich habe er gesagt durch die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben ist die sehr
dynamische entwicklung aus mit dem märz
beherrschbar geworden durch die maßnahme
so und das ist ein sehr wichtiger punkt
jetzt eben auch für das was da aus
daraus folgt nämlich der ansatz der ja
auch vereinbart worden ist am mittwoch
schrittweise und vorsichtig eben in eine
rückkehr in eine neue normalität
sozusagen zu kommen bestimmte maßnahmen
jetzt jetzt auf absehbare zeit brauchen
alltags massen sind gerade angesprochen
worden in bestimmten bereichen abstand
halten
auch das ja jeden tag wieder aufs neue
für jeden von uns zum lernen wie wir das
am besten umsetzen und im alltag seien
auch miteinander durch tragen die dinge
bleiben und ich finde den ansatz den wir
in deutschland gemeinsam haben zu sagen
wir machen schrittweise erste
lockerungen schauen nach zwei wochen
weil wir dann auch in der entwicklung
der infektionszahlen einen ersten
eindruck haben da ist ja immer ein
zeitverzug drin was machen diese
maßnahmen mit dem infektionsgeschehen
und bewährten nach zwei wochen neu und
gehen dann möglicherweise einen nächsten
schritt dass das ein sehr vorsichtiger
ausbalancierter ansatz in einer
unsicheren lage ist meine feste
überzeugung ist schlechter wäre der
ansatz erst mal großzügig öffnen um
anschließend nachher wieder was
zurücknehmen zu müssen ich glaube ein
hin und her in den maßnahmen was weniger
verlässlichkeit am ende bedeutet ist
schwieriger auch am ende in der
akzeptanz sondern vermitteln als dieser
schrittweise ansatz alle zwei wochen zu
schauen welche nächsten schritt können
wir dann entsprechend gehen und in
dieser balance werden wir das dann eben
jetzt auch weiter an geht übrigens einen
wichtigen hinweis mal auch zu der
automobilindustrie
es war keine politische entscheidung
dass im produzierenden gewerbe in
deutschland im moment kurzarbeiter
sollen die kurzarbeit in diesen
bereichen hat zu tun damit das
absatzmärkte weggebrochen sind
es hat gerade keine gute zeit und
maschinen und autos in die welt zu
verkaufen weil eben in den allermeisten
ländern die märkte gar nicht mehr
funktionieren das waren keine
politischen entscheidung das finde ich
manchmal wichtig in der debatte es gibt
bestimmte bereiche da sind politische
entscheidungen gewesen wo wir auch
unterstützen gastronomie tourismus
andere bereiche und es gibt dann
bereiche die sind betroffen durch die
weltwirtschaftslage und europäische
wirtschaftslage und diesen unterschied
müssen wir in der debatte auch machen ja
ganz kurz zu ihrer frage also wie
dunkelziffer kann ich ihnen immer noch
nicht gut berechnen ja weil wir ja diese
antikörper test durchführen
repräsentative studien
dann werden wir die dunkelziffer besser
kennen wir wissen aus modellierungen
können wir bestimmte annahmen rausgeben
aber ich sag mal so sagen wir mal wir
hätten was was alle fachleute für hoch
halten sagen wir mal wir hätten eine
zehnfache dunkelziffer dann hätten wir
rund 1,3 millionen infizierte nur das
sind trotzdem sehr wenig ja also nochmal
das ist wirklich wichtig zu verstehen
dass es eine pandemie ist ein virus was
weltweit unterwegs ist was nicht
verschwindet und die an eine pandemie
ende dann wenn 60 bis 70 prozent einer
bevölkerung infiziert wurden durch sorgt
sind sozusagen also da ist noch sehr
viel zeit das heißt also was wir tun
müssen ist wir müssen sehr viele
werkzeugen etablieren das haben wir in
den letzten wochen wirklich sehr
erfolgreich getan um zu messen um so gut
wie möglich zu messen da wird sehr viel
getan insbesondere gilt es hier die
lokalen gesundheitsämter wirklich stark
zu unterstützen
mit verschiedenen werkzeugen sind zu
einem menschen da sind zum einen auch
digitale tools damit die arbeit dort
schneller noch präziser gemacht werden
kann und dann messen wir jederzeit immer
was geschieht und die dunkelziffer
werden wir ihnen sagen können wenn wir
diese repräsentativen studien machen
aus lokalen studien ist es schwer auf
die dunkelziffer für die gesamte
bevölkerung zu schließen weil das
geschehen epidemiologisch lokal
unterschiedliches die nächste frage hat
der welt auf eine frage an den minister
spanier spannen sie haben in den letzten
wochen und monaten mit zwei maßstäben
argumentiert im wesentlichen das eine
war die verdopplung skater am anfang das
zweite setzt der sogenannte r faktor das
gibt ein bisschen durcheinander und auch
wenn diese beiden zahlen zusammen hängen
haben sie manchmal das gefühl gehabt
oder haben sie jetzt das gefühl in der
rückschau dass sie manchen der fragen so
zu sagen hätten genauer und intensiver
und noch transparenter für alle zu
erklären erklären müssen
eine frage an ein bieler auch wenn diese
beiden zahlen zusammenhängen sind die
eigentlichen widerspruch oder sind die
sozusagen zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
der pandemie der richtige der richtige
wert den man sozusagen anlegen muss und
es eigentlich mich die zahl der
neuinfektionen die er wird mit 3.000
immer noch hoch ist eigentlich das
wirkliche problem und nicht 07 weil 3000
werden wir pro tag nicht kontrollieren
können im sinne von wir suchen die leute
die mit denen zusammen getroffen sind
jetzt haben sie ja in ihrer antwort in
dieser frage schon ein teil der antwort
geben er fällt also zum ersten die
verdoppelung zeit war ein parameter in
der debatte jetzt auch gar nicht zuerst
vom robert-koch-institut und uns
getriggert aber unabhängig davon ein
eine zahl in der debatte vor allem für
exponentielles wachstum in einer zeit wo
sie exponentielle steigerungen haben wie
wir sie hatten in der ersten märzhälfte
macht durchaus sinn auch das thema
verdopplung zeit für die
infektionszahlen im blick zu haben für
eine zeit jetzt wo wir lineare
entwicklung haben in den absoluten
zahlen und auch in den steigerungen ist
eben auch vor allem diese
reproduktionsrate also die frage in
einfachen worten wie viel steckt jemand
der infiziertes noch an eins heißt einen
anderen wichtig die reproduktionsrate
die kamera aussagen war mit dem märz
richtung 34 unterwegs also eine hat drei
vier andere angesteckt und wenn sie das
mal durchgehen von denen drei und dann
noch einmal drei und dann geht das ja
ganz schnell eben in dieses
exponentielle wachstum was wir aber
immer gesagt haben ist es weder der eine
noch der andere parameter und der
professor weder hat gerade darauf
hingewiesen alleine für sich genommen
schon alles erklären kann oder daraus
sich ableiten lässt denn die ihr hinweis
darauf dass die absolute zahl auch eine
wichtige rolle spielt ist ja richtig was
fängt an bei der kapazität des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst 5000 neue
infizierte am tag von 375 lokalen
gesundheitsämtern zu identifizieren und
nachzuverfolgen ist glaube ich noch
schaffbar ist natürlich unterschiedlich
betroffenen regional 50.000
nachzuverfolgen alle kontakte ist
jedenfalls ohne technologie sicher nicht
schafft mit den ressourcen den
personellen und einfach den kapazitäten
die daten die frage gilt dann auch für
die intensivmedizin
wir können ja voraus berechnen von 1000
die sich heute infizieren mit bestimmten
annahmen wie viele werden intensiv
pflicht ich in zehn tagen in aller regel
die intensiv richtigkeit geht bis zu 20
tage wenn sie einen entsprechenden
sicherheitspuffer sozusagen auch
einbauen können sie hochrechnen wie aus
1000 infizierten jeden tag dann die
intensiv kapazität nötig ist um das
entsprechend abzudecken
das sind jetzt noch mal zwei weitere
faktoren die eine rolle spielen was ich
damit sagen will mit genutzt
andere anfügen es gibt nicht die eine
zahl wie das manchmal in der
öffentlichen debatte suggeriert wird die
ganz alleine eine aussagekraft darüber
hat wo wir stehen und ob wir damit
umgehen können so das ist das
zusammenspielen und das zusammen
betrachten verschiedener faktoren
und tatsächlich haben wir in einem immer
recht
das müssen wir so häufig es geht so gut
es geht immer wieder aufs neue auch
erklären und und herleiten das machen
wir auch auf unsere in unseren online
arbeit in sozialen medien aber auch auf
den seiten des robert koch instituts
aber ich nehme das gerne als auftrag mit
ist noch häufiger zu machen ja ich kann
dem nicht hinzuzufügen das ist der punkt
also das eine sind die reihen
epidemiologischen daten die wir immer im
auge haben müssen
darum müssen wir ebenso gut und genau
sein und und so aktuell wie möglich das
haben wir in den letzten wochen ja
wirklich gemeinsam viel anstrengung
gemacht um das zu verbessern
auch gesetzliche änderungen und das
zweite ist eben dann die kapazität auf
der anderen seite des gesundheitssystems
und das ist ein
eine berechnung von von kapazitäten
gegen möglichkeiten die man immer im
auge haben muss
das ist der entscheidende punkt es sind
viele faktoren und nochmal ist wirklich
wir haben ja über die wochen
strategische bekämpfung pläne
aufgebauten strategisches vorgehen immer
mal wieder angepasst und das gehört
zusammen und das muss man im gesamt
spiel betrachten das ist nicht trivial
aber auch ich nehme diesen auftrag an
das war das besser erklären müssen die
nächste frage wer heute von uns aus
gesehen links ja danke schön hier
ich habe einmal ein bis zwei fragen an
das befahren und zwar bräuchte es gibt
jetzt mehrere selbsttests die menschen
zu hause machen können die auf das bekam
zugelassen hat als medizinprodukt wie
schätzen sie die eigentlich persönlich
ein
ist es sinnvoll dass sie man sich sowas
bestellt ist das eine das zweite ist sie
hatten vorher schon gesprochen über die
queen die für die medikamente die jetzt
im krankenhaus
angewendet werden gibt es in deutschland
denn da schon individuellen heilversuch
möglichkeiten oder auch projekte die
jetzt gerade stattfinden
zum letzteren zu den kolloquien da gab
es hinweise die wir auch gerade für
individuelle halver suche gemacht haben
dann haben wir aber von den apotheken
und den hersteller zurück gemeldet
bekommen haben unkontrollierte abflüsse
das wetter unkontrolliert eingesetzt
offensichtlich und dann haben wir das
auch wieder zurückgenommen und es hat
dann eben auch einschränkungen erlassen
damit eben zum beispiel rheuma patienten
in dieser arzneimittel jeden tag auch
brauchen sie auch weiter bekommen können
und da wollen wir einfach diese risiken
die jetzt mit den fluglinien auch gerade
was jetzt herzerkrankungen angeht das
auch kontrollieren und im auge behalten
was die selbst test angeht gibt es da
auch einige missverständnisse das auch
geht das bva angefragt worden ist nach
bedingungen unter denen eine sonde
zulassung notwendig ist da ist aber
nicht automatisch dann eine zulassung
durch das bva moderne entwicklung mit
dem bv also da möchte ich mich auch
gegen verwehren da werden wir teilweise
auch benutzen es gibt im moment noch
keine guten selbsttests das ist so und
das möchte ich auch sehr betonen
herr vision ein falsches micro dass herr
minister nachfrage nach der app setzt
sich doch abzeichnet dass google und
apple zusammen schneller sind in der app
entwicklung und eine programmentwicklung
als deutschland europa wäre das dann aus
ihrer sicht sinnvoll die hoheit über
diese app die zulassung dann google und
apple zu überlassen und nicht weiter
selbst zu vorstellen was sicherlich und
ohne zweifel hilfreich ist und die
zusammenarbeit und die kontakte gibt es
ja auch ist natürlich auch das
unternehmen wie google und apple weil am
ende muss es ja auch auf den viel
gebräuchlichen endgeräten zum beispiel
natürlich auch funktionieren
teil dieser entwicklung und der debatte
sind
gleichzeitig erwische mayer sind wir
eine gemeinsamen teil auch einer debatte
zu datenschutz und datensicherheit und
gerade bei der frage wer hat mit wem
kontakt und intensiveren gehabt geht es
ja auch um sensible daten und deswegen
ist aus unserer sicht auch wichtig bei
entwicklungen aller anderen beteiligten
dass datenschutz und datensicherheit
dabei eine sehr sehr große rolle spielt
und zwar nach europäischem recht
ja also albrecht leipzigs media das eine
ist in der frage an einsparen das andere
ein wiler die sie haben mehrmals jetzt
schon von normalität gesprochen was hat
denn das für konsequenzen oder was soll
das für konsequenzen haben für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst der ja in
der länderhoheit ist wie müsste man dann
neue diskussionen führen und dann
entweder die frage es gibt immer wieder
diskussionen darüber ob die toten ancona
sterben oder mit corona und wie kann man
denn hier genauer hingucken und wie
relevant ist die frage und wie kriegen
wir da verlässlichere daten der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst der vor
allem einer in den landkreisen und
kreisfreien städten ist bei den
gesundheitsämtern spielt eine sehr
wichtige rolle gerade in einer
epidemischen lage wie dieser zur
wahrheit gehört dass er in den letzten
jahren nicht immer die aufmerksamkeit
auch in den ressourcen bekommen hat in
allen bereichen und in allen regionen
die er verdient hätte und die ja
offensichtlich auch braucht gleichzeitig
bin ich sehr dankbar für das bemühen der
länder wie der kommunen in der letzten
wochen zu verstärken auch personell zu
verstärken wir haben auch
förderprogramme seitens des bundes
finanziert was entsprechende teams
angeht die helfen bei der kontakt nach
verfolgung medizin studierende die mit
einspringen und anderes mehr
und wir planen auch weitere
unterstützung die die technische
ausrüstung angehen
im jahr 2020 sind manche der
kommunikationswege des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes auf allen ebenen
miteinander
bis dann zur die kommunikation auch zum
robert-koch-institut noch nicht auf dem
stand auf dem sie sein sollten
wir können das aber natürlich jetzt in
der krise auch nur so machen dass nicht
das umstellen mehr kraft kostet als
gerade eigentlich gehen müsste in die
krise selbst und deswegen aber das
werden die nächsten tage vorstellen
arbeiten wir auch da an einer stärkung
ja das ist wohl die stunde von public
health höhe so oft sagen
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst ihren
bus jetzt gestärkt werden da gibt es
viele anstrengungen das macht viele
menschen sehr froh das ist gut und
wichtig und richtig
ihre frage zu zudem ob man an oder mit
stirbt ich halte also die die frage kann
man natürlich nur durch intensive
medizinische betreuung durch ärzte
beantworten woran ein patient stirbt und
letztlich auch in dem jedem einzelfall
wenn man die person obduzieren würde
dann könnte man über die todesursache
mehr sagen wobei auch nochmals gesagt
also auch nicht jeder obduktion führt
wirklich eindeutig dazu herauszuheben
woran jetzt genau der patient verstorben
ist ich halte die debatte aber ehrlich
gesagt für akademisch ich halte sie in
bezug auf die zahlen also auf den
gesamten impact der krankheit für die
todeszahlen in deutschland nicht für
wirklich relevant denn es gibt definitiv
natürlich auch fälle wo menschen ankommt
versterben die nicht portiert werden
also das heißt ich sehe das nicht als
eine relevante größe an und ich möchte
in dem zusammenhang auch noch mal kurz
auf nachbarländer verweisen wo wir ja
wirklich teilweise sehr große zahlen
haben menschen die versterben dem see
new york city dort sind inzwischen mehr
als 10.000 menschen verstorben
ich halte es da für eine akademische
diskussion ob man dann prozent mehr oder
weniger spricht das ist eine andere
problematik wenn eine pandemie die wir
so stark wie möglich einschränken
müssten dann versuchen wir eine kurze
frage von herrn kreutzfeldt hallo 2002
ganz kurze wenn ich darf zum einen auch
mal zum thema tests da musste ich zum
einen gern ersparen sie haben gesagt wir
haben jetzt eine kapazität von über
700.000 pro woche durchgeführt wurden
zuletzt aber nur 350.000 pro woche war
woran scheitert es denn eigentlich dass
wir jetzt unsere kapazitäten auch nutzen
und zu der zahl der positiven tests
nicht etwas verwirrt da sprachen sie von
zehn prozent der wähler von 9
werke bericht stand 8,1 was stimmt denn
nun und zu den intensiv patienten noch
ganz kurz gibt es die eigentlichen der
zahlen wie viele patienten trotz
intensivmedizinischer behandlung
anteilig versterben das letzte hat der
wähler dankbar sagt der professor wähler
und 30% versterben in der
intensivmedizin in der beatmung im
moment so witt das zweite das ist mir
die frage wer im parameter sie nehmen
über alle 17 millionen tests es ist
glaube ich 8,1 prozent gewesen positiv
manchmal in manchen wochen war es 10
es ist immer um die zehn prozent in
aller regel leicht runter je nachdem
welche woche sie betrachten
deswegen wir ja sagen das zeigt
eigentlich wie breit wir testen
andere länder haben zum teil 20 30 mehr
prozent positiv getestet zeigte aber
eben auch automatisch dass das
dunkelfeld dadurch größer ist an der
stelle
350.000 wurden gemacht 700.000 ist die
theoretische technische kapazität sie
brauchen dann natürlich auch die
reagenzien und die vorprodukte dazu und
im übrigen auch die fähigkeit des
gesundheitswesens also ärzte und andere
dass die tests überhaupt abzunehmen was
wir die letzten tage erstmalig hatten
seit längerem ist dass die test
kapazität gar nicht vollumfänglich auch
nicht die der reagenzien genutzt worden
ist das heißt also dieser backlog
diesmal gab dass man zwei drei tage da
brachten musste bis etwas tatsächlich
dann durchlaufen konnte die situation
haben wir im moment nicht und wir sind
als bunt zusammen mit laboren und
reagenzien und vorprodukte herstellern
nicht nur in gesprächen sondern
mittlerweile auch in sehr konkreten
vertragsabschlüsse um weitere test
vorprodukt kapazitäten sozusagen für
deutschland auch zu sichern für den
weiteren aufbau mit der bitte um
verständnis dass wir nicht alle fragen
geschafft haben wir endlich diese
pressekonferenz dank ist das kommen
damit eigentlich im gästen fürs kommen
bleiben sie gesund